This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。绝对真人。嗨，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）主持的《以难得的方式学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出了一个信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你需要这么做，请收听
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,|||《Learn the Hard Way》，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.|||更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即 TWO%，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.|||请收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is great to have you here for another episode. Today,
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is great to have you here for another episode. Today,|||与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克（Jemma Spike），欢迎回到《你的二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十岁时的最大变化、时刻和转变以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。很高兴你能来到这里收听另一期节目。今天，
let's talk about how we are going to get our personalities back. How are we going to reclaim who we are from the forces of scrolling and overconsumption and comparison and distraction? I have come to a pretty scary realization over the past months that although I may think I know who I am, I rarely actually act out the parts of myself that I most enjoy or that I pride myself on. And because of that, I'm in this like really aimless, lonely, hollow kind of distracted place where like, I don't really know who I am anymore. And maybe you've had a similar experience, a similar realization. A lot of who we think we are is just words.
let's talk about how we are going to get our personalities back. How are we going to reclaim who we are from the forces of scrolling and overconsumption and comparison and distraction? I have come to a pretty scary realization over the past months that although I may think I know who I am, I rarely actually act out the parts of myself that I most enjoy or that I pride myself on. And because of that, I'm in this like really aimless, lonely, hollow kind of distracted place where like, I don't really know who I am anymore. And maybe you've had a similar experience, a similar realization. A lot of who we think we are is just words.|||我们来聊聊如何找回我们的个性。我们该如何从刷手机、过度消费、攀比和分心的力量中夺回真正的自我？在过去的几个月里，我得出一个相当可怕的认识：尽管我可能觉得自己很了解自己，但我实际上很少表现出自己最喜欢或引以为傲的那部分特质。正因如此，我处于一个非常漫无目的、孤独、空虚且分心的状态中，甚至觉得我不再真正了解自己了。也许你也有过类似的经历，类似的领悟。我们所认为的自我，很大程度上其实只是空洞的言语。
You know, our actions don't always reflect it. And if someone was to ask you, you know, how would you describe yourself? How do you spend your days? What are your hobbies? What do you care about what do you do for fun? A lot of us, you know, we may not like to admit it, but we don't have an answer. We spend so much of our time consuming and scrolling and working that we don't really have a clear or at least an executed idea of the person that we are. This is how that expresses itself. You may not want to acknowledge that this is what's happening to you, but if you are feeling detached, if you are feeling an increasing sense of anxiety, that you don't know who you are, you aren't where you need to be, if you feel boredom, loneliness,
You know, our actions don't always reflect it. And if someone was to ask you, you know, how would you describe yourself? How do you spend your days? What are your hobbies? What do you care about what do you do for fun? A lot of us, you know, we may not like to admit it, but we don't have an answer. We spend so much of our time consuming and scrolling and working that we don't really have a clear or at least an executed idea of the person that we are. This is how that expresses itself. You may not want to acknowledge that this is what's happening to you, but if you are feeling detached, if you are feeling an increasing sense of anxiety, that you don't know who you are, you aren't where you need to be, if you feel boredom, loneliness,|||你知道，我们的行动并不总是能反映出这一点。如果有人问你，你知道的，你会如何描述自己？你是如何度过每一天的？你的爱好是什么？你在乎什么？你平时都做什么来消遣？我们中的很多人，你知道的，可能不愿意承认，但我们根本答不上来。我们把太多的时间花在了消费、刷手机和工作上，以至于我们对自己的真实模样并没有一个清晰的、或者至少是付诸实践的认知。这就是它的表现形式。你可能不想承认这就是发生在你身上的事情，但如果你感到疏离，如果你感到越来越焦虑，不知道自己是谁，不在自己应该在的地方，如果你感到无聊、孤独，
just like despondency in your life, if there's like a groundhog day sense of every day being the same, this may be what's happening. You have lost your personality. And I want to talk about how we are going to rediscover it again using actual psychology, evidence-based tools and tips that can let us become our best selves or at least discover the parts of ourselves, rediscover the parts of ourselves that we really, really like. You are not alone in this experience. Trust me. And investing in getting your personality back, finding what you care about and what makes
just like despondency in your life, if there's like a groundhog day sense of every day being the same, this may be what's happening. You have lost your personality. And I want to talk about how we are going to rediscover it again using actual psychology, evidence-based tools and tips that can let us become our best selves or at least discover the parts of ourselves, rediscover the parts of ourselves that we really, really like. You are not alone in this experience. Trust me. And investing in getting your personality back, finding what you care about and what makes|||生活就像陷入了土拨鼠之日般每天都在重复，那么这可能就是原因所在。你已经失去了你的个性。我想谈谈我们将如何利用现实中的心理学、基于证据的工具和技巧来重新发现它，这些工具和技巧能让我们成为最好的自己，或者至少发现我们自己的一部分，重新发现那些我们非常非常喜欢的自我部分。有这种经历的不止你一个人。相信我。投入精力找回你的个性，找到你在乎的事物以及是什么让你
you want to strive, I think will mend a lot of like the deep psychological, I don't want to say holes, like wounds, psychological deficiencies that, so many of us are experiencing on a daily basis. So we are going to run through seven tips for how I've done this, how I've seen other people do this, how they've reconnected with the best parts of themselves that they've may be lost. I'm really excited for this episode. Without further ado, let's jump into it. So you guys know one of my favorite quotes of all time comes from Carl Jung. It is that the privilege of a lifetime is to become who you truly are. That is your mission. Even when everything else feels really scary, if you are at least discovering new facets and sides to yourself, you are, you're doing something
you want to strive, I think will mend a lot of like the deep psychological, I don't want to say holes, like wounds, psychological deficiencies that, so many of us are experiencing on a daily basis. So we are going to run through seven tips for how I've done this, how I've seen other people do this, how they've reconnected with the best parts of themselves that they've may be lost. I'm really excited for this episode. Without further ado, let's jump into it. So you guys know one of my favorite quotes of all time comes from Carl Jung. It is that the privilege of a lifetime is to become who you truly are. That is your mission. Even when everything else feels really scary, if you are at least discovering new facets and sides to yourself, you are, you're doing something|||想要去奋斗，我认为这将修复许多深层的心理——我不想说是洞，而是像伤口一样——许多我们当中每天都在经历的心理缺陷。所以，我们将快速梳理七个技巧，关于我是如何做到这一点的，我是如何看到其他人做到这一点的，以及他们是如何重新与自己可能已经失去的最好部分建立联系的。我真的对这期节目感到非常兴奋。话不多说，让我们直接切入正题。所以你们知道，我最喜欢的名言之一来自卡尔·荣格（Carl Jung）。那就是：一生的特权，就是成为真正的自己。这就是你的使命。即使当其他一切都让人感到非常害怕时，如果你至少在发现自己崭新的侧面和面貌，你就是在做
right. Now, becoming who you are means kind of understanding who you've been shaped into so far and then how you want to shape yourself from here on out deliberately or what you want to become. And that is the part that is up to you and that is the part that requires effort and like a mindset shift. People really assume that your personality is like what you are essentially born with. It's so natural to us that you just fall into it, you remain in it, you don't have to work on it. It is God given, predetermined. And to some degree that is right. You know, there is a part of us that just seems to like exist without influence. There is our natural temperament. which often remains quite stable.
right. Now, becoming who you are means kind of understanding who you've been shaped into so far and then how you want to shape yourself from here on out deliberately or what you want to become. And that is the part that is up to you and that is the part that requires effort and like a mindset shift. People really assume that your personality is like what you are essentially born with. It's so natural to us that you just fall into it, you remain in it, you don't have to work on it. It is God given, predetermined. And to some degree that is right. You know, there is a part of us that just seems to like exist without influence. There is our natural temperament. which often remains quite stable.|||正确的事情。现在，成为你自己意味着去理解你迄今为止被塑造、变成了什么样的人，然后思考从今以后你想要如何刻意地塑造自己，或者你想成为什么样的人。这部分是完全取决于你自己的，这也是需要付出努力和思维转变的部分。人们总以为你的个性就像是你生来就具备的东西一样。它对我们来说太自然了，以至于你顺理成章地陷入其中，停留在其中，根本不需要为之努力。它是上帝赋予的，是命中注定的。在某种程度上，这确实是对的。你知道，我们身上确实有一部分似乎不受任何外界影响而存在。那就是我们天生的气质，它通常保持得相当稳定。
Some of us have talents that we were like simply born with and there's like no other explanation for it. But it's also a lot more complex than that. Essentially personality and our self concept, which is basically just a fancy word for how we see ourselves in our mind's eye. It comes down to a few things. Genetics, the blueprint is one component. According to a 2020 study published in nature that looked at, twins, which is like the highest standard for these kinds of studies, human personality is around 40 to 60% heritable. 40 to 60% of who you are in some way comes down to who your parents are
Some of us have talents that we were like simply born with and there's like no other explanation for it. But it's also a lot more complex than that. Essentially personality and our self concept, which is basically just a fancy word for how we see ourselves in our mind's eye. It comes down to a few things. Genetics, the blueprint is one component. According to a 2020 study published in nature that looked at, twins, which is like the highest standard for these kinds of studies, human personality is around 40 to 60% heritable. 40 to 60% of who you are in some way comes down to who your parents are|||我们中的一些人拥有仿佛生来就有的天赋，对此似乎没有别的解释。但它也远比这要复杂得多。从本质上讲，个性和我们的自我概念（这其实只是一个用来形容我们在心中如何看待自己的高级词汇）归结于几件事。基因，也就是蓝图，是其中的一个组成部分。根据2020年发表在《自然》杂志上的一项研究，该研究调查了双胞胎（这堪称这类研究的最高标准），人类的个性有大约40%到60%是可以遗传的。你在某种程度上的40%到60%归结于你的父母是谁
or, you know, the DNA that you have inherited. 40 to 60% though is like a pretty big margin. Like that's, that shows that we don't really have that much of an accurate estimate because a 20% could go this way, could go that way, is, I don't know, not something I want to stake my odds on. I like to split the difference. Let's say 50%, 50% of who you are is, you know, genetics, is your parents, is DNA. Another 30% has to do with environment. So gender, culture, personal experiences, upbringing, education, country, trauma, those kinds of things. That leaves 20%, or probably more, that is entirely up to you. And that final part, that final 20%,
or, you know, the DNA that you have inherited. 40 to 60% though is like a pretty big margin. Like that's, that shows that we don't really have that much of an accurate estimate because a 20% could go this way, could go that way, is, I don't know, not something I want to stake my odds on. I like to split the difference. Let's say 50%, 50% of who you are is, you know, genetics, is your parents, is DNA. Another 30% has to do with environment. So gender, culture, personal experiences, upbringing, education, country, trauma, those kinds of things. That leaves 20%, or probably more, that is entirely up to you. And that final part, that final 20%,|||或者，你知道的，你所继承的DNA。不过，40%到60%是一个相当大的幅度。这表明我们并没有一个真正准确的估计，因为20%可能会倾向于这边，也可能会倾向于那边，我不知道，这不是我想押注的事情。我喜欢折中一下。假设50%，你身上50%的成分是，你知道的，基因，是你的父母，是DNA。另外30%与环境有关。比如性别、文化、个人经历、成长背景、教育、国家、创伤，诸如此类的事情。这就剩下了20%（或者可能更多），这完全取决于你。而最后那一部分，最后那20%，
acts with great intensity on the remaining 80%. And I think it basically determines how all those other factors, environment, upbringing, genetics is expressed. So basically what I'm trying to say is that your choices to do with your personality and how you feel about yourself and how you feel about yourself and how you want your personality to be expressed, that at the end of the day accounts
acts with great intensity on the remaining 80%. And I think it basically determines how all those other factors, environment, upbringing, genetics is expressed. So basically what I'm trying to say is that your choices to do with your personality and how you feel about yourself and how you feel about yourself and how you want your personality to be expressed, that at the end of the day accounts|||对剩下的80%起着极其强烈的作用。我认为它基本上决定了所有其他因素（环境、成长背景、基因）将如何表达。所以基本上我想说的是，你关于自己的个性、你对自己的看法、你对自己的感受以及你希望自己的个性如何表达的选择，归根结底占了
could end up accounting for 100% of who you actually become. How you go about your personality and your life, yes, it might not be able to change the past or change your genetic blueprint, but it can change how you approach all those other factors. Maybe the reason you've lost yourself is because up until this point, you've let your personality simply be the byproduct,
could end up accounting for 100% of who you actually become. How you go about your personality and your life, yes, it might not be able to change the past or change your genetic blueprint, but it can change how you approach all those other factors. Maybe the reason you've lost yourself is because up until this point, you've let your personality simply be the byproduct,|||最终可能会占到你实际成为什么样的人的100%。你如何对待你的个性和生活，是的，它可能无法改变过去或改变你的基因蓝图，但它能改变你对待所有其他因素的方式。也许你失去自我的原因是因为直到现在，你都让你的个性仅仅成为了一种副产品，
of the things you have no control over and have simply accepted. Now, you're at a stage where you're noticing that that's maybe harmful and you don't feel good anymore, but you're also at a stage where you can actually put in the work and you can approach your personality and the parts of you that you feel you've become disconnected from in a very proactive manner. So with all of that in mind, let's get into my number one tip. number one go back to a simpler time i read this amazing idea the other day you don't lose your personality you freeze it somewhere between childhood and adulthood you just suddenly you just suddenly stopped doing all the things that you loved you know at some stage you you played for the last time
of the things you have no control over and have simply accepted. Now, you're at a stage where you're noticing that that's maybe harmful and you don't feel good anymore, but you're also at a stage where you can actually put in the work and you can approach your personality and the parts of you that you feel you've become disconnected from in a very proactive manner. So with all of that in mind, let's get into my number one tip. number one go back to a simpler time i read this amazing idea the other day you don't lose your personality you freeze it somewhere between childhood and adulthood you just suddenly you just suddenly stopped doing all the things that you loved you know at some stage you you played for the last time|||是你无法控制、只能全盘接受的事物的副产品。现在，你处于这样一个阶段：你注意到这可能是有害的，你不再感觉自在了，但你同时也处于这样一个阶段：你可以真正付出努力，并且能够以一种非常积极主动的方式来对待你的个性以及那些你觉得已经与自己疏离的部分。带着所有这些想法，让我们进入我的第一条建议。第一条：回到一个更简单的时代。前几天我读到一个绝妙的想法：你并没有失去个性，而是把它冻结在了童年和成年之间的某个地方；你只是突然之间，突然就不再做所有你曾经热爱的事情了，你知道的，在某个阶段，你最后一次玩耍
At some stage, you made up imaginary worlds for the last time. You stopped crafting on the weekends. Remember when you were a kid and you'd be like, you know what, today's the day I learned how to make lemonade. Or like, today's the day that I write a song. Today's the day that I like run around the neighborhood with my friends. We don't do that anymore. We just spend seven hours a day on TikTok,
At some stage, you made up imaginary worlds for the last time. You stopped crafting on the weekends. Remember when you were a kid and you'd be like, you know what, today's the day I learned how to make lemonade. Or like, today's the day that I write a song. Today's the day that I like run around the neighborhood with my friends. We don't do that anymore. We just spend seven hours a day on TikTok,|||在某个阶段，你最后一次虚构了想象中的世界。你不再在周末做手工艺品。还记得你小时候，你会觉得，你知道吗，今天就是我学会做柠檬水的一天。或者像，今天就是我写歌的一天。今天就是我喜欢和朋友们在街区里到处跑的一天。我们不再那样做了。我们只是每天花七个小时在TikTok上，
consuming other people's lives whilst they perform for us, pretending they have lives of their own. A part of us that used to come alive during those moments, during those times of childhood wonder and delight has become frozen by inactivity and a lack of use. But what that means is that doing what your childhood or younger self enjoyed most is probably how you're going to find the missing piece of your personality that you're looking for. The piece that you kind of left in the past. you've got to start doing the things that you used to love doing as a child again as an adult.
consuming other people's lives whilst they perform for us, pretending they have lives of their own. A part of us that used to come alive during those moments, during those times of childhood wonder and delight has become frozen by inactivity and a lack of use. But what that means is that doing what your childhood or younger self enjoyed most is probably how you're going to find the missing piece of your personality that you're looking for. The piece that you kind of left in the past. you've got to start doing the things that you used to love doing as a child again as an adult.|||消费别人的生活，而他们在为我们表演，假装他们有自己的生活。我们身上有一部分曾在那些时刻、在那些童年的惊叹与快乐的时光中活跃起来的灵魂，如今却因不活动和缺乏使用而被冻结了。但这意味著，去做你童年或年幼时的自己最享受的事情，可能就是你找到寻找中缺失的个性拼图的方式。那个你有点丢在过去的部分。你必须在成年后重新开始做那些你小时候喜欢做的事情。
And finding your way back to that joy that you had and that just like pure interest. So much of who we are is just like so raw and visible when we are children. Because because of the very psychological nature of childhood itself, you know, our little minds are open to so much. We have such a natural curiosity, but as children, we also follow the path of natural enjoyment with incredible ease because there's less, if not nothing, stopping you from doing that. You know, for example, a child who loves art can make art all weekend and just enjoy it because they don't have to worry about it being good. They don't have to worry, hopefully, about obligation, some children do, but hopefully they don't have to worry about getting dinner ready or, you know, how exhausted they are from, work or FOMO or all the other things they could be doing with their time, productivity. You know, a child who loves reading just feels the positive reward of reading without thinking
And finding your way back to that joy that you had and that just like pure interest. So much of who we are is just like so raw and visible when we are children. Because because of the very psychological nature of childhood itself, you know, our little minds are open to so much. We have such a natural curiosity, but as children, we also follow the path of natural enjoyment with incredible ease because there's less, if not nothing, stopping you from doing that. You know, for example, a child who loves art can make art all weekend and just enjoy it because they don't have to worry about it being good. They don't have to worry, hopefully, about obligation, some children do, but hopefully they don't have to worry about getting dinner ready or, you know, how exhausted they are from, work or FOMO or all the other things they could be doing with their time, productivity. You know, a child who loves reading just feels the positive reward of reading without thinking|||并找回你曾拥有的那种快乐以及那种纯粹的兴趣。我们本质的很大一部分，在童年时期是那么的纯真和显而易见。因为由于童年本身纯粹的心理本质，你知道的，我们幼小的心灵对外界敞开得如此之多。我们有着如此天生的好奇心，但作为孩子，我们也以令人难以置信的轻松顺应了天生享受快乐的道路，因为阻碍你这么做的阻碍微乎其微，甚至没有。你知道，例如，一个热爱艺术的孩子可以画一整个周末的画，单纯地享受其中，因为他们不必担心画得好不好。希望他们不用担心义务（有些孩子会担心，但希望他们不用），不用担心准备晚饭，或者，你知道的，他们因为工作或错失恐惧症（FOMO）或者可以用时间去做、去追求生产力的其他所有事情而感到多麽精疲力竭。你知道，一个热爱阅读的孩子只是感受到阅读带来的积极回报，而不会去想
if it's productive, without thinking if other people think it's cool. It's the natural flow of joy that is uninterrupted by adult judgments, uninterrupted by adult frustrations and realism and responsibilities. that is why we probably felt most like ourselves when we were small. And it really reflects a lot of what we know about in a child healing and play and connecting with our younger selves as a path to authenticity in adulthood. So that's where I need you to return. Find an activity you loved as a child, the one you can remember enjoying the most,
if it's productive, without thinking if other people think it's cool. It's the natural flow of joy that is uninterrupted by adult judgments, uninterrupted by adult frustrations and realism and responsibilities. that is why we probably felt most like ourselves when we were small. And it really reflects a lot of what we know about in a child healing and play and connecting with our younger selves as a path to authenticity in adulthood. So that's where I need you to return. Find an activity you loved as a child, the one you can remember enjoying the most,|||这是否有效率，也不会去想别人是否觉得这很酷。这是一种自然流淌的快乐，它没有被成人的判断所打断，没有被成人的挫败感、现实主义和责任所打断。这就是为什么我们在年幼时可能感觉最像自己。这确实反映了许多我们所了解的内容：关于儿童时期的疗愈、玩耍以及与年轻的自我连接，作为通往成年期真实自我的途径。所以这就是我需要你回归的地方。找一个你小时候喜欢的活动，那个你记得最享受的活动，
doing the most, and incorporate it into your daily routine. In fact, literally put it on your to-do list at first. you know, the way that you would put personal hygiene or your fitness routine or your work priorities on your to-do list. You know, you're fighting back against some pretty powerful forces here who want to distract you from your personality. Your phone is a literal slot machine in your pocket. Busy schedules, exhaustion, the pressure to work more. You can't fight those forces randomly. You need a plan. You need to make it a priority to paint, a priority to play the piano. to make Lego, to go play sports, to craft, make sure it's on your to-do list.
doing the most, and incorporate it into your daily routine. In fact, literally put it on your to-do list at first. you know, the way that you would put personal hygiene or your fitness routine or your work priorities on your to-do list. You're fighting back against some pretty powerful forces here who want to distract you from your personality. Your phone is a literal slot machine in your pocket. Busy schedules, exhaustion, the pressure to work more. You can't fight those forces randomly. You need a plan. You need to make it a priority to paint, a priority to play the piano. to make Lego, to go play sports, to craft, make sure it's on your to-do list.|||花最多时间去做的活动，并把它融入你的日常生活中。事实上，一开始甚至可以把它直接写进你的待办事项清单里。你知道的，就像你会把个人卫生、健身习惯或工作优先级写进待办事项清单那样。你在这里是在与一些非常强大的力量抗争，它们试图让你从你的个性中分心。你的手机就是你口袋里的名副其实的老虎机。忙碌的日程、筋疲力尽、要求工作更多的压力。你无法凭运气去对抗这些力量。你需要一个计划。你需要把画画当作一个优先级，把弹钢琴当作一个优先级。拼乐高，去参加体育运动，做手工艺，确保它在你的待办事项清单上。
And if you want to go even smaller and you want to really reconnect with that inner child version of you who felt most pure and like yourself, even just listen to your favorite childhood music on your way to work or on your commute or when you cook dinner. Music is actually a deeply emotional trigger and listening to nostalgic music can actually cue a similar mindset to the time you first heard the song. therefore really bringing you back to that simpler time and bringing back with it that same attitude, spirit, feeling, sense of authenticity, as long as you make it a priority. This brings me to tip number two.
And if you want to go even smaller and you want to really reconnect with that inner child version of you who felt most pure and like yourself, even just listen to your favorite childhood music on your way to work or on your commute or when you cook dinner. Music is actually a deeply emotional trigger and listening to nostalgic music can actually cue a similar mindset to the time you first heard the song. therefore really bringing you back to that simpler time and bringing back with it that same attitude, spirit, feeling, sense of authenticity, as long as you make it a priority. This brings me to tip number two.|||如果你想做得更细微一些，并且真的想与那个内心深处感觉最纯真、最像自己的童年版自己重新建立联系，甚至只需在上班路上、通勤途中或做晚饭时听听你童年最喜欢的音乐。音乐实际上是一个深刻的情感触发器，听怀旧音乐实际上可以唤起一种类似于你第一次听到这首歌时的心态。因此，只要你把它当作一个优先级，它就能真正把你带回到那个更简单的时代，并带回那种态度、精神、感觉和真实感。这就引出了我的第二条建议。
Make sure that you are fulfilling one of your core soul needs per day. Soul needs are the spiritual things you do to feel your cup purely by feeling human. It doesn't have to be productive. It's purely by practicing the things that make us unlike anything else on the planet. And when I say spiritual, I don't mean religious. I don't mean prayer. That can be part of it for you. I mean the stuff that makes you feel like you literally, you have a soul. These include adventure and curiosity. That is a soul need. Playfulness and silliness. Being seen and kinship. Humor and laughter. deep enjoyment or indulgence, you know, really spending extra time making your dinner, feeling the warmth of the sun, spending an extra five minutes in bed, sex or deep physical connection with yourself or others, or and creating something that didn't exist this morning. So those are some of your soul needs. Your soul needs are the things that make you sentient, alive, feeling. Specifically though, they make you feel,
Make sure that you are fulfilling one of your core soul needs per day. Soul needs are the spiritual things you do to feel your cup purely by feeling human. It doesn't have to be productive. It's purely by practicing the things that make us unlike anything else on the planet. And when I say spiritual, I don't mean religious. I don't mean prayer. That can be part of it for you. I mean the stuff that makes you feel like you literally, you have a soul. These include adventure and curiosity. That is a soul need. Playfulness and silliness. Being seen and kinship. Humor and laughter. deep enjoyment or indulgence, you know, really spending extra time making your dinner, feeling the warmth of the sun, spending an extra five minutes in bed, sex or deep physical connection with yourself or others, or and creating something that didn't exist this morning. So those are some of your soul needs. Your soul needs are the things that make you sentient, alive, feeling. Specifically though, they make you feel,|||确保你每天满足自己的一项核心灵魂需求。灵魂需求是你为了纯粹通过体验做人来丰盈内心而进行的精神活动。它不必具有生产力。它纯粹是通过践行那些让我们区别于地球上任何其他事物的行为来实现的。当我说是精神上的时，我指的不是宗教。我指的不是祈祷。对你来说那可能是其中的一部分。我指的是那些让你觉得你真切地拥有一个灵魂的东西。这些包括冒险和好奇心。这是一种灵魂需求。好玩和傻气。被看见与亲密感。幽默与欢笑。深深的享受或纵情，你知道的，真正花额外的时间做晚饭，感受阳光的温暖，在床上多赖五分钟，性或者与自己或他人建立深刻的身体连接，或者创造出今天早上还不存在的东西。所以这些就是你的一些灵魂需求。你的灵魂需求是那些让你有知觉、有生命、有感觉的事物。具体来说，它们让你感受到，
not like a machine. Often we lose our personalities because we do craft our daily lives to reflect that more of a machine. And machines, they don't have personalities. Like, AI doesn't have a personality. A truck doesn't have a personality. A lawnmower, a typewriter doesn't have a personality unless we, as humans, the sentient creatures, apply it onto them. So how can you expect yourself to have a personality? How can you expect yourself to know who you are. If you act like a machine, if your daily life is, get up, plug in, commute, water, eat, operate in, out, produce, go home, turn off. That's really what like the daily, like daily life is trying to push us into becoming or is incidentally pushing us into becoming. You have to act out against that. There was a recent paper I read
not like a machine. Often we lose our personalities because we do craft our daily lives to reflect that more of a machine. And machines, they don't have personalities. Like, AI doesn't have a personality. A truck doesn't have a personality. A lawnmower, a typewriter doesn't have a personality unless we, as humans, the sentient creatures, apply it onto them. So how can you expect yourself to have a personality? How can you expect yourself to know who you are. If you act like a machine, if your daily life is, get up, plug in, commute, water, eat, operate in, out, produce, go home, turn off. That's really what like the daily, like daily life is trying to push us into becoming or is incidentally pushing us into becoming. You have to act out against that. There was a recent paper I read|||而不是像一台机器。通常我们失去个性，是因为我们确实把日常生活设计得更像一台机器。而机器是没有个性的。就像，人工智能没有个性。卡车没有个性。割草机、打字机也没有个性，除非我们这些作为人类的有知觉的生物将个性赋予它们。所以你怎么能期望自己拥有个性呢？你怎么能期望自己了解自己是谁。如果你像机器一样行事，如果你的日常生活是：起床、通电、通勤、浇水、吃饭、运转、进出、生产、回家、关机。这确实是日常，就像日常生活正试图把我们推向的方向，或者无意中把我们推向的方向。你必须采取行动去对抗这一点。我最近读过一篇论文
about burnout due to monotony, not just excess work. That was so fascinating. You know, we typically think of burnout as just having too much on your plate, having too much going on. Essentially what this paper was saying, that actually making your life too simplistic and having too much routine can be psychologically harmful and can become actually quite exhausting and destructive. routine can be really protective only up to a point when there is no room for soul,
about burnout due to monotony, not just excess work. That was so fascinating. You know, we typically think of burnout as just having too much on your plate, having too much going on. Essentially what this paper was saying, that actually making your life too simplistic and having too much routine can be psychologically harmful and can become actually quite exhausting and destructive. routine can be really protective only up to a point when there is no room for soul,|||关于单调导致的精疲力竭，而不仅仅是因为工作过多。这太迷人了。你知道，我们通常认为精疲力竭只是因为手头事情太多，要处理的事情太多。这篇论文实质上在说，实际上让你的生活过于简单化、有太多例行公事，在心理上可能是有害的，并且实际上会变得相当令人筋疲力尽和具有破坏性。例行公事只有在某种程度上才能真正起到保护作用，当没有空间容纳灵魂时，
when there is no room for deviation from your routine. That's why we end up losing ourselves. So your soul needs, I need you to add them back into your life. I need you to sprinkle them back into your life like your childhood activities. I also will say this is probably the quickest tip of all on this list. Fulfill one soul need a day for a month. hit as many categories as you can and I promise money back guarantee right here you will be feeling honestly brand new you will be feeling better than ever you will like people will notice the difference
when there is no room for deviation from your routine. That's why we end up losing ourselves. So your soul needs, I need you to add them back into your life. I need you to sprinkle them back into your life like your childhood activities. I also will say this is probably the quickest tip of all on this list. Fulfill one soul need a day for a month. hit as many categories as you can and I promise money back guarantee right here you will be feeling honestly brand new you will be feeling better than ever you will like people will notice the difference|||当没有空间允许偏离你的常规时。这就是我们最终失去自我的原因。所以你的灵魂需求，我需要你把它们加回到你的生活中。我需要你像对待童年活动一样，把它们重新点缀回你的生活。我还要说，这可能是这份清单上最快见效的建议。连续一个月，每天满足一个灵魂需求。尽可能多地涵盖不同的类别，我向你保证，在此承诺包退款，老实说你会感觉焕然一新，你会感觉比以往任何时候都好，你会发现人们会注意到其中的区别
in you they will see something shining out of you that they haven't seen for a while or that you haven't seen or felt for a while either okay we are going to take a short break here before we return for our next three tips. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
in you they will see something shining out of you that they haven't seen for a while or that you haven't seen or felt for a while either okay we are going to take a short break here before we return for our next three tips. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.|||在你身上，他们会看到某种从你身上散发出来的光芒，那是他们一段时间以来未曾见过的，或者也是你一段时间以来未曾见过或感受到的。好的，我们在进入接下来的三个建议之前，先在这里短暂休息一下。所以请继续收听。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越统治健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.|||我们曾坚信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即 T-W-O-Persent，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，绝对不要惹乡村女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific. con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific. con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.|||玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也绝对不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在新一季的《The Girlfriends》中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己采取行动。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye's... said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye's... said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.|||我说，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。请收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）……说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.|||我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）合作的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一整天可卡因，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们第二期讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的脉络。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.|||我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你帮我把话说完。是的。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth,
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth,|||欢迎来到我的新播客《以难得的方式学习》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了呼应心理健康意识月，我将带来我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与众多杰出的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你们觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，
or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.|||还是你做一个好人是因为你感到害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你们能真正做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。
This next strategy is one that I frequently rely on in my own, I guess, emotional, psychological toolbox. I've spoken about it on the podcast before. I just have to mention it again because it is so important for people to know. This is my question for you. Do you ever feel like you are your best self when you are traveling? You are your best self when you are on holiday and suddenly you have, like all of these crazy ideas for projects, businesses, a rebrand. Do you find that like you are so much more productive when you study at the library or like
This next strategy is one that I frequently rely on in my own, I guess, emotional, psychological toolbox. I've spoken about it on the podcast before. I just have to mention it again because it is so important for people to know. This is my question for you. Do you ever feel like you are your best self when you are traveling? You are your best self when you are on holiday and suddenly you have, like all of these crazy ideas for projects, businesses, a rebrand. Do you find that like you are so much more productive when you study at the library or like|||接下来的这个策略是我经常在自己的情感和心理工具箱中依赖的策略。我以前在播客中谈到过它。我不得不再次提及它，因为它对人们了解自己太重要了。这是我给你的问题。你是否曾觉得自己在旅行时是最好的自己？你在度假时是最好的自己，突然之间，你有了所有这些关于项目、商业、品牌重塑的疯狂想法？你是否发现，当你在图书馆学习时，你的效率要高得多，或者像
at your national or institutional library rather than the one that you typically study at? Or that you are so much more productive after a hike after you've been outdoors. These are all leading questions. You're probably going to say yes. What you are experiencing in the same. moment is the psychological power of geographical novelty, specifically the power of a new environment. This is somewhat similar to our last tip, but it focuses mainly on like your location. If you want to get your personality back, like you've got to be putting yourself in new
at your national or institutional library rather than the one that you typically study at? Or that you are so much more productive after a hike after you've been outdoors. These are all leading questions. You're probably going to say yes. What you are experiencing in the same. moment is the psychological power of geographical novelty, specifically the power of a new environment. This is somewhat similar to our last tip, but it focuses mainly on like your location. If you want to get your personality back, like you've got to be putting yourself in new|||在你的国家图书馆或机构图书馆学习，而不是在你通常学习的那个图书馆？或者你在户外徒步之后，效率会高得多。这些都是引导性问题。你大概会说是的。你在同一时刻体验到的是地理新鲜感的心理力量，特别是新环境的力量。这与我们上一条建议有点相似，但它主要集中在你的地理位置上。如果你想找回你的个性，你必须把自己置于新的
environments. There is this fantastic, could not recommend enough series of research by the researcher David Gonzalez and his team that they conducted between, I think it was like, late 2000, like 2017, 2018, where they essentially explored the importance of novelty for our memory,
environments. There is this fantastic, could not recommend enough series of research by the researcher David Gonzalez and his team that they conducted between, I think it was like, late 2000, like 2017, 2018, where they essentially explored the importance of novelty for our memory,|||环境中。研究人员大卫·冈萨雷斯（David Gonzalez）及其团队在2000年代末期（大概是2017、2018年左右）进行了一系列精彩绝伦、怎么推荐都不为过的研究，他们在研究中探讨了新鲜感对我们记忆的重要性，
for our neural health, and crucially for our personality. And they found that when looking at, like, thousands of people, literally thousands of people of all ages, all ethnicities, all cultures, all genders,
for our neural health, and crucially for our personality. And they found that when looking at, like, thousands of people, literally thousands of people of all ages, all ethnicities, all cultures, all genders,|||对我们神经健康的重要性，以及至关重要的是，对我们个性的重要性。他们发现，在观察成千上万的人时——字面意思上来自各个年龄段、各个族裔、各种文化、各种性别的数千人——
those who had novel experiences, those who put themselves in new environments, tried new things, tried new food, music, movies, were so much happier. And they also had a deeper sense of personal enlightenment and they knew who they were. For example, one 2017 study in particular observed production workers who were given novel tasks once a shift and they found that afterwards these people felt better about themselves. They had more grey matter in their brains compared to those who didn't have these novel experiences, who didn't have to solve unfamiliar problems.
those who had novel experiences, those who put themselves in new environments, tried new things, tried new food, music, movies, were so much happier. And they also had a deeper sense of personal enlightenment and they knew who they were. For example, one 2017 study in particular observed production workers who were given novel tasks once a shift and they found that afterwards these people felt better about themselves. They had more grey matter in their brains compared to those who didn't have these novel experiences, who didn't have to solve unfamiliar problems.|||那些拥有新奇体验的人，那些把自己置于新环境中、尝试新鲜事物、尝试新食物、新音乐、新电影的人，要快乐得多。他们对个人启蒙也有更深的体悟，并且他们清楚自己是谁。例如，2017年的一项研究特别观察了生产工人，他们在每个班次中会被分配一次新奇的任务，研究人员发现，事后这些人对自己的感觉更好了。与那些没有这些新奇体验、不需要解决不熟悉问题的人相比，他们大脑中的灰质更多。
What that means for you is give yourself new, curious challenges, get into new spaces, get into new environments wherever you can, different routes to work, walk a different way to work every single day just for fun, studying in a new library, going to a different coffee shop rather than your favorite. it. Even like watching something new at night instead of the same episode of the office for like the fifth time in a row, which I am very much guilty of, you know, the reason this is helpful for getting our personality back is because it ensures that our brains remain plastic and adaptable. Your brain was built for newness. It was built to be challenged and inspired by the world to taste berries, to experience awe, to meet new people, to see new types of trees. And when it doesn't get that,
What that means for you is give yourself new, curious challenges, get into new spaces, get into new environments wherever you can, different routes to work, walk a different way to work every single day just for fun, studying in a new library, going to a different coffee shop rather than your favorite. it. Even like watching something new at night instead of the same episode of the office for like the fifth time in a row, which I am very much guilty of, you know, the reason this is helpful for getting our personality back is because it ensures that our brains remain plastic and adaptable. Your brain was built for newness. It was built to be challenged and inspired by the world to taste berries, to experience awe, to meet new people, to see new types of trees. And when it doesn't get that,|||这对你的意义在于：给自己设定新的、充满好奇心的挑战，尽可能进入新的空间、进入新的环境，尝试不同的上班路线，为了好玩每天走不同的路去上班，在新的图书馆学习，去一家不同的咖啡店而不是你最喜欢的那家。甚至比如晚上看点新鲜的东西，而不是连续第五遍看同一集的《办公室》（The Office）——对此我深感内疚，你知道的，这之所以有助于我们找回个性，是因为它确保了我们的大脑保持可塑性和适应性。你的大脑生来就是为了追求新鲜事物而建造的。它生来就是为了接受世界的挑战和启发，去品尝浆果，去体验敬畏，去结识新朋友，去欣赏各种新奇的树木。而当它得不到这些时，
I kind of imagine it like turns into like a zoo animal of sorts, like a tiger, you know, pacing up and down, pacing up and down, its cage, kind of trapped in by the, by the boringness of things. And you will feel the difference in the wiring of your brain when you make this a priority. your brain moves from stagnant and bored, like, you know, a river with no flow to like expansive and rushing and curious and fresh. I just think it is like one of the easiest things you could do tomorrow to feel more like yourself just by like opening your brain up a little bit more to the world. Okay, tip number four, you will start to see a theme here at this point. Have a completely unproductive goal and make it really, really random, like totally weird,
I kind of imagine it like turns into like a zoo animal of sorts, like a tiger, you know, pacing up and down, pacing up and down, its cage, kind of trapped in by the, by the boringness of things. And you will feel the difference in the wiring of your brain when you make this a priority. your brain moves from stagnant and bored, like, you know, river with no flow to like expansive and rushing and curious and fresh. I just think it is like one of the easiest things you could do tomorrow to feel more like yourself just by like opening your brain up a little bit more to the world. Okay, tip number four, you will start to see a theme here at this point. Have a completely unproductive goal and make it really, really random, like totally weird,|||我有点想象它就像变成了一只动物园里的动物，比如一只老虎，你知道的，在它的笼子里来回踱步，来回踱步，被事物的无聊感所困住。当你把这作为优先事项时，你会感受到大脑神经布线上的差异。你的大脑从停滞和无聊（就像一条没有流动的水流）转变为广阔、奔涌、充满好奇和新鲜感。我只是觉得这可能是你明天就能做的最简单的事情之一，只需让你的大脑对世界更加开放一点，就能让自己感觉更像自己。好的，第四条建议，此时你将开始看到这里的一个主题。设定一个完全没有生产力的目标，让它变得非常非常随机，比如完全怪异，
totally separate from everything else you're doing in life. You can call it a side quest, a side quest, if you will, that will take effort and time, but does not feel exhausting nor productive or like productive in one sense of the world. Let me kind of explain what I mean by this. Let me give you some examples. of what I mean by these side quests or these unproductive goals. For example, read five biographies about artists you admire. Memorize all 196 flags.
totally separate from everything else you're doing in life. You can call it a side quest, a side quest, if you will, that will take effort and time, but does not feel exhausting nor productive or like productive in one sense of the world. Let me kind of explain what I mean by this. Let me give you some examples. of what I mean by these side quests or these unproductive goals. For example, read five biographies about artists you admire. Memorize all 196 flags.|||与你生活中在做的其他所有事情完全脱节。你可以称之为支线任务，如果你愿意的话，这是一个需要付出努力和时间，但又不会让人感到筋疲力尽，也没有生产力（或者说在世俗意义上的生产力）的目标。让我来解释一下我这话的意思。让我举几个例子来说明我所说的支线任务或这些无生产力的目标是什么意思。例如，阅读五本关于你钦佩的艺术家的传记。记住全部196面国旗。
Go to every museum in the town, city, place where you live before the end of the year. Paint a portrait for every single one of your friends by the end of the year. Learn how to make your own clothes. You know, the best example of this is if you've read the book slash saying, movie Julian Julia, where this woman basically is like, I'm going to cook my way through a Julia child cookbook in one year. That is a great example. That is an, you know, I hate using the word unproductive, but unproductive for her other ambitions, an unproductive goal that still feels nourishing and is difficult. I think the core element of this is that it adds a bit of
Go to every museum in the town, city, place where you live before the end of the year. Paint a portrait for every single one of your friends by the end of the year. Learn how to make your own clothes. You know, the best example of this is if you've read the book slash saying, movie Julian Julia, where this woman basically is like, I'm going to cook my way through a Julia child cookbook in one year. That is a great example. That is an, you know, I hate using the word unproductive, but unproductive for her other ambitions, an unproductive goal that still feels nourishing and is difficult. I think the core element of this is that it adds a bit of|||在年底前去遍你居住的城镇、城市、地方的每一家博物馆。在年底前为你的每一位朋友画一幅肖像。学习如何自己做衣服。你知道，最好的例子就是如果你读过书或看过电影《朱莉与朱莉娅》（Julie & Julia），里面那个女人基本上就是说：我要在一年内把朱莉娅·查尔德（Julia Child）食谱上的菜全部做一遍。那是一个极好的例子。那是一个，你知道的，我讨厌用“无生产力”这个词，但对于她的其他雄心壮志来说是没有生产力的，一个仍然让人感到滋养且充满挑战的无生产力目标。我认为这其中的核心要素是，它为你的生活增添了一点儿
whimsy and a lack of seriousness back into your life whilst still asking you to strive in a direction that you normally don't. All of those weird goals I gave you, like they are achievable with effort. They also tap into something we've really been discussing this whole episode, which is like a sense of wonder and a humanness and a curiosity that we've probably lost along the way at some point. what is the psychological justification for this? The psychological justification for setting an unproductive goal as a means to reconnect with your personality is that it's diversifying your personality. The way people diversify investments, it's ensuring that you have multiple avenues,
whimsy and a lack of seriousness back into your life whilst still asking you to strive in a direction that you normally don't. All of those weird goals I gave you, like they are achievable with effort. They also tap into something we've really been discussing this whole episode, which is like a sense of wonder and a humanness and a curiosity that we've probably lost along the way at some point. what is the psychological justification for this? The psychological justification for setting an unproductive goal as a means to reconnect with your personality is that it's diversifying your personality. The way people diversify investments, it's ensuring that you have multiple avenues,|||异想天开和不那么严肃的玩味，同时仍然要求你朝着一个你通常不会涉足的方向努力。我给你的所有那些奇怪的目标，只要付出努力都是可以实现的。它们还触及了我们在整期节目中一直在讨论的东西，那就是一种惊叹感、人性以及我们在沿途某个时刻可能已经丢失的好奇心。这背后的心理学依据是什么？将设定无生产力的目标作为重新连接你个性的手段，其心理学依据在于它使你的个性多样化。就像人们分散投资一样，它确保了你有多条途径，
multiple streams through which you are able to investigate and explore and see yourself. You cannot be defined by one thing, one thing like work or, study or your business and think that that's going to deliver you a happy life. In our 20s particularly, you know, there is this major emphasis on being focused, selective, choosing one path to specialize in, whether it's choosing a major, choosing a sport, choosing a hobby, choosing a literal career path, and just like being on that until you retire, basically concentrating all your effort on one thing for the next 40, 50 years. You know, even I feel like at times I am guilty of that because having that focus does bring results,
multiple streams through which you are able to investigate and explore and see yourself. You cannot be defined by one thing, one thing like work or, study or your business and think that that's going to deliver you a happy life. In our 20s particularly, you know, there is this major emphasis on being focused, selective, choosing one path to specialize in, whether it's choosing a major, choosing a sport, choosing a hobby, choosing a literal career path, and just like being on that until you retire, basically concentrating all your effort on one thing for the next 40, 50 years. You know, even I feel like at times I am guilty of that because having that focus does bring results,|||有多条渠道让你能够去审视、探索并认识自己。你不能被单一的事物所定义，比如工作、学习或你的商业生意，并认为这就能为你带来幸福的生活。尤其是在我们的20多岁时，你知道的，社会非常强调专注、有选择性、选择一条路专攻，无论是选择专业、选择一项运动、选择一个爱好、选择一个字面意义上的职业道路，然后就沿着这条路一直走到退休，基本上在接下来的40、50年里将你所有的精力集中在一件事上。你知道，甚至连我有时也觉得自己犯了这样的错误，因为拥有这种专注确实能带来成果，
but does it make you feel alive if you have nothing else going on in your life? Does it make you feel connected to who you are? Let's be honest, not all the time. We get that laser focus and everything else fades away. And so what happens? What happens when things, when that thing isn't satisfying anymore? What happens when you get fired? What happens when you want to change when the main focus drops off?
but does it make you feel alive if you have nothing else going on in your life? Does it make you feel connected to who you are? Let's be honest, not all the time. We get that laser focus and everything else fades away. And so what happens? What happens when things, when that thing isn't satisfying anymore? What happens when you get fired? What happens when you want to change when the main focus drops off?|||但如果你的生活中没有其他任何事情发生，它会让你觉得自己还活着吗？它会让你觉得自己与真正的自我有连接吗？说实话，并非总是如此。我们获得了那种激光般的专注力，而其他一切都黯然失色。然后会发生什么呢？当事情、当那件事不再令人满意时会发生什么？当你被解雇时会发生什么？当主要焦点减弱而你想要改变时会发生什么？
You're kind of left with like a bit of a wasteland. You're left contemplating who you are and life feels very narrow because it's almost like, there's going to be a weird metaphor. It's almost like you've put these glimplating. glasses on that narrow your focus and then you take them off and you expect your eye to suddenly be able to to see what's out on the periphery and what's out all around despite not giving it the opportunity to for many, many years. And now that I'm saying it sounds like a stupid analogy, but it's just, that's just how I see it in my mind of like you're literally blinding yourself
You're kind of left with like a bit of a wasteland. You're left contemplating who you are and life feels very narrow because it's almost like, there's going to be a weird metaphor. It's almost like you've put these glimplating. glasses on that narrow your focus and then you take them off and you expect your eye to suddenly be able to to see what's out on the periphery and what's out all around despite not giving it the opportunity to for many, many years. And now that I'm saying it sounds like a stupid analogy, but it's just, that's just how I see it in my mind of like you're literally blinding yourself|||你有点像被留在一片废墟之中。你留下来沉思自己是谁，生活感觉非常狭隘，因为这几乎就像——这里会有一个奇怪的比喻。这几乎就像你戴上了那种限制你视野的眼镜，缩小了你的焦距，然后你摘下眼镜，期望你的眼睛突然能够看到周边以及周围的所有事物，尽管多年来你根本没有给它这种机会。现在我说出来觉得这像是个愚蠢的比喻，但这正是我脑海中的看法，就像你简直是在让自己变成盲人，
to everything else by not giving your eyes or your vision or your personality the opportunity to explore. That's why I need you to be collecting these side quests. Consider it personality insurance. If the things you typically base your personality on, work, relationships, accolades, praise, passion, if those things fade, they become exhausting. This way you'll still know who you are. And you'll still be able to connect with the deeper part of you
to everything else by not giving your eyes or your vision or your personality the opportunity to explore. That's why I need you to be collecting these side quests. Consider it personality insurance. If the things you typically base your personality on, work, relationships, accolades, praise, passion, if those things fade, they become exhausting. This way you'll still know who you are. And you'll still be able to connect with the deeper part of you|||通过不给你的眼睛、你的视线或你的个性提供探索的机会，从而对其他一切视而不见。这就是为什么我需要你去收集这些支线任务。把它当作个性保险。如果你通常赖以建立个性的事物——工作、人际关系、荣誉、赞美、激情——如果这些东西消退了，它们变得令人筋疲力尽。通过这种方式，你仍然会知道自己是谁。你仍然能够与你内心更深的部分建立联系，
because you're expressing yourself elsewhere in a way that feels meaningful, in a way that doesn't feel tied to anything to do with your career or work or those kind of things of importance. It's just something you're doing and want to give a red hot go. Actually, I had this as a fifth tip, this next one, but I think it may come under this one. So I'm just going to include it here. My fifth tip was going to be, such kind of still is,
because you're expressing yourself elsewhere in a way that feels meaningful, in a way that doesn't feel tied to anything to do with your career or work or those kind of things of importance. It's just something you're doing and want to give a red hot go. Actually, I had this as a fifth tip, this next one, but I think it may come under this one. So I'm just going to include it here. My fifth tip was going to be, such kind of still is,|||因为你在其他地方以一种感觉有意义的方式表达自己，这种方式感觉与你的职业、工作或那些重要的事情毫无关系。这只是你正在做并且想要全力以赴尝试的一件事。事实上，我原本把接下来的这点作为第五条建议，但我认为它可能属于这一条的范畴。所以我干脆把它包含在这里。我的第五条建议原本是（某种程度上现在仍然是），
to start journaling, specifically commit to a year of junk journaling. Talk about life-changing micro-habits. This one is it. I started junk journaling. recently after my friend Sally recommended it to me, she's the most beautiful woman on the planet of this earth. She's just like remarkable. And I had this conversation with her middle of last year where I was like,
to start journaling, specifically commit to a year of junk journaling. Talk about life-changing micro-habits. This one is it. I started junk journaling. recently after my friend Sally recommended it to me, she's the most beautiful woman on the planet of this earth. She's just like remarkable. And I had this conversation with her middle of last year where I was like,|||开始写日记，具体来说是承诺进行一年的垃圾手帐（junk journaling）创作。谈到改变人生的微习惯。这个就是了。我开始做垃圾手帐。最近在我的朋友莎莉（Sally）向我推荐之后，她是这个地球上最美丽的女人。她简直太卓越了。去年年中我和她有过这样一次对话，当时我说：
Sally, like, I don't know who I am anymore. I don't know who I am without my phone. I don't know who I am without work. All I want to do is work will be on my phone. Work will be on my phone. Like I don't find myself interested or interesting anymore. and she was like, you got to get one of these junk journals that everybody on Instagram's been talking about. Like, you've got to get just a journal and just collect literal trash. And I was like,
Sally, like, I don't know who I am anymore. I don't know who I am without my phone. I don't know who I am without work. All I want to do is work will be on my phone. Work will be on my phone. Like I don't find myself interested or interesting anymore. and she was like, you got to get one of these junk journals that everybody on Instagram's been talking about. Like, you've got to get just a journal and just collect literal trash. And I was like,|||“莎莉，我不知道我是谁了。离开手机我不知道我是谁。离开工作我不知道我是谁。我只想工作或者盯着手机。工作就在我的手机上。就像我不再觉得自己有趣，或者对事物感兴趣了。”然后她说：“你得去买一本Instagram上大家都在讨论的那种垃圾手帐。就是买一本手帐，然后去收集字面意义上的垃圾。”然后我说：
okay, I'll just try it because I trust her opinion. And what I found is that it's basically journaling on easy mode. I love journaling, just like out my feelings onto the page in an unstructured manner. But when I really don't feel like I have the energy for that, this is like the best alternative. You basically just collect junk like receipts, labels, stickers, train tickets, airplane tickets, whatever it is from your day, from your life. You get a glue stick, you paste it in your journal, and you just write small comments about it and, you know, how this junk is basically reflecting your kind of life story in a weird way. And it's given me such a sense of firstly, it's a really important ritual and a habit that I do every single night in a systematic
好吧，我打算试一试，因为我相信她的眼光。我发现这基本上就是简化版的写日记。我喜欢写日记，就像是以一种无结构的方式把我的情绪倾泻在纸上。但当我真的觉得自己没有精力这样做时，这就成了最好的替代方案。你基本上只是收集生活中的各种废旧杂物，比如收据、标签、贴纸、火车票、飞机票，不管是什么。你拿一支胶棒，把它贴在日记本里，然后写下一些简短的评论，你知道的，看看这些废物是如何以一种奇妙的方式反映出你的人生故事的。这让我首先产生了一种感觉，这是一个非常重要的仪式和习惯，我每天晚上都在系统性地
way that has been grounding. It's also given me such a sense of self-continuity. Basically, being able to look back and see who I was three weeks ago, who I was a month ago, and hopefully in the future being able to look back and see who I was now. And what I've seen, being my own case study, is that we find our personality through this process because by doing this, by journaling or junk journaling, we add narrative back into our lives. This is a core premise of narrative psychology. We like when something has a story to it that we can reflect on, including our own lives. We love a story.
这样做，这让我感到很踏实。它也赋予了我一种强烈的自我延续感。基本上，能够回过头来看看三个月前的我是谁，一个月前的我是谁，并且希望在未来能够回过头来看看现在的我是谁。通过我自己的切身经历，我发现我们通过这个过程找到了我们的个性，因为通过这样做——通过写日记或垃圾手帐，我们把叙事重新融入了我们的生活。这是叙事心理学的一个核心前提。我们喜欢有故事可讲、值得我们反思的事物，包括我们自己的生活。我们都爱听故事。
We love when something feels coherent because there is a line that goes all the way through. Journaling in whatever form does that for us. We can coherently draw lines between our thoughts and our experiences. We can observe ourselves in the past and in the present. We see patterns in behaviors. We notice things about who we are because we are the specimen. We are the subject under the microscope. And that just helps us recognize the parts of us that we love,
我们喜欢那种前后连贯、有一条贯穿始终的线索的感觉。无论以何种形式，写日记都能为我们做到这一点。我们可以在我们的思想和经历之间连贯地划出界限。我们可以观察过去和现在的自己。我们能看出行为的模式。我们注意到关于我们是谁的事情，因为我们就是标本。我们就是显微镜下的主体。这正好帮我们认出了我们热爱的那些部分，
that we may be forgetting, that we may be missing. Dare I say it that we may be. avoiding. Basically, journaling is like a mirror. I think that is why it is such a well-worn tested therapy or self-help method because it just lets you see yourself without, I guess, the frills that we put on for other people. With the junk journal, like you literally see yourself through garbage. Like that is as raw and real as it can get. Bonus to this as well. And this is why I started in the first place. It gets you off your fucking phone. If you want to get your personality back, and I know I've said this before, you've got to
那些我们可能已经遗忘、可能已经错失的部分。我甚至敢说，那些我们可能一直在逃避的部分。基本上，写日记就像一面镜子。我想这就是为什么它是一种历久弥新、屡试不爽的治疗或自助方法，因为它能让你赤裸裸地看到自己，而没有我们为了迎合别人而刻意加上的那些浮华装饰。有了垃圾手帐，你简直就是通过垃圾看到了最真实的自己。这就是最原始、最真实的状态。这也是它的额外好处。这也是我最初开始做的原因。它能让你远离该死的手机。如果你想找回你的个性，而且我知道我以前说过这话，你必须
stop consuming and start creating. There is a very famous saying, you are what you eat, you are also the digital content and digital world that you consume. How can you hope to be your own individual, your own unique figure to have your own personality if you just consume other people's personalities for nourishment. Consumption is like, you're scrolling, consumption being on your phone, it's like feeding your brain artificial stuff all day. Creation is like feeding it organic strawberries and vegetables and like delightful things that actually give it nutrients. One more bonus to this, and I'm sorry, then we can move on with the journaling thing, but just to beat this horse dead. I think that it also not just lets you see who you are now, it lets you see yourself in the future.
停止消费，开始创造。有一句非常著名的名言，人如其食，你也是你所消费的数字内容和数字世界。如果你只是把别人的个性当作营养来汲取，你又怎么能期望成为独立的个体、独特的自我并拥有自己的个性呢？消费就像是，你在刷手机，消费手机上的内容就像是一整天都在给你的大脑喂食人造物品。而创造就像是给它喂食有机草莓、蔬菜和那些真正能提供营养的美味。还有一个好处，抱歉，然后我们就可以继续讨论写日记的事了，但我得把这个话题彻底说透。我认为它不仅能让你看到现在的自己，还能让你看到未来的自己。
Let me elaborate on this a little bit. In five years' time, in 25 years' time, you may be at a similar point as the one you're at now, where you're like, who am I? I don't know who I am. What is my actual personality? And now, because you started journaling, junk journaling, whatever it is at this point, you will have 5, 10, 15, 25 years worth of information to help you reconnect with yourself and remind you what has made you you.
让我对此详细说明一下。五年后，二十五年后，你可能会处于与现在类似的阶段，当时你会想，我是谁？我不知道我是谁。我真正的个性是什么？而现在，因为你从此时开始写日记、做垃圾手帐，无论是什么形式，你都将拥有价值5年、10年、15年、25年的信息，来帮助你重新与自己建立联系，并提醒你是什么造就了现在的你。
My listeners who have been journaling for a little bit for a long time, maybe even their whole lives, can confirm this for me. There are few pleasures as amazing as sitting down with a glass of wine or a tea and reading back your old journals. Every time I move house, I do this, it's the best. I like run away with the day. I like lose hours to just like reexamining myself through myself and like reading what I thought about this guy Ralph
那些已经写了一段时间日记、很长时间甚至可能是一辈子的听众可以为我这一点作证。没有什么快乐能比泡上一杯酒或茶，坐下来阅读自己过去的日记更美妙的了。每次搬家我都会这么做，这感觉太棒了。我会思绪飞扬。我会花上好几个小时，通过自己来重新审视自己，比如阅读我对这个叫拉尔夫的家伙的想法，
who I was like had a crush on in year 8 or like this girl Lucinda who was like mean to me in year 5 because it's all there. And it's funny like how I reacted and how I. wrote and how I approach those things then is kind of similar to how I act now. And that's really gratifying in that it's, it's nice to see the continuity. So yeah, it's sacred, it's spiritual. It's a gift not just for your current self, but for your future self as well. So yeah, totally recommend doing that if you don't feel like yourself right now. Okay, we have to take one more short break here, but then I have two final tips for you. The last one, honestly being the one that I've
我在8年级时曾暗恋过他，或者对这个叫露辛达的女孩的想法，她在5年级时对我很刻薄，因为这一切都在那里。有趣的是，我当时的反应、写作方式以及处理这些事情的方式，与我现在的行为方式有点相似。这真的令人欣慰，看到这种连续性感觉真好。所以，是的，这是神圣的，是精神上的。这不仅是给现在的自己的一份礼物，也是给未来的自己的一份礼物。所以，是的，如果你现在觉得自己不在状态，我完全推荐你这么做。好了，我们在这里还要休息一小会儿，接下来我还有最后两个建议。老实说，最后一个建议是我所有的建议中
would recommend the most out of all of these. So I promise you it's worth it, stick with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
最推荐的一个。所以我向你们保证，这是值得的，请继续收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健身以及在这个奇异的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力造成的。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。就在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，搜索T-W-O-P-e-r-s-e-n-t。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
自作自受，咎由自取。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在这个新季的《闺蜜》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他一定会得到他应得的下场。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
就在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
好吧，你可以在播客节目《Look Back at it》中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，畅谈80年代的快克毒品。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
需要明确的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克毒品。我随时准备聊聊毒品这个话题，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们第二次讨论毒品。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还谈到了艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
而我们仍在追逐，却不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同的信任层级。我希望你纯粹是因为想做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the hard way. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. I will say a lot of these tips so far have been kind of solitary, very like things that we do in like the quiet of our home. But we really know ourselves a lot of the time and see ourselves through others and through their appreciation of us. If you don't know who you are, your friends and
加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。我想说，到目前为止，许多这些建议都有些孤立，非常像我们在自己家的安静角落里做的事情。但在很多时候，我们其实是通过他人以及他们对我们的欣赏来真正了解自己、看清自己的。如果你不知道自己是谁，你的朋友和
family probably do and they love you for it. So you have to start asking them questions about yourself as if you don't know yourself. Questions like, hey, you know, like what song reminds you the most of me? What movie makes you think of me? What was I really like as a child? What is your favorite memory of us together and why is it so important? What do you think my biggest skill is? What is my biggest weakness that I don't know about? What are some words that you would use to describe? me to a stranger, like, almost like all these weird kinds of questions, and it might sound and feel awkward at first, and then it feels really nourishing that there is a version of you that exists and that is stable and other people see it and they love you. This tip works psychologically because
家人可能知道，而且他们深爱着这样的你。所以你必须开始向他们提出关于你自己的问题，就好像你不了解自己一样。比如这些问题：“嘿，你知道的，哪首歌最能让你想起我？”“哪部电影会让你想到我？”“我小时候到底是什么样子的？”“你对我们在一起最美好的回忆是什么，为什么它如此重要？”“你觉得我最大的技能是什么？”“我有什么自己不知道的最大弱点？”“你会用什么词来形容
of one of the oldest ideas in social psychology, actually, it is Charles Horton-Cooley's idea of the looking glass self. I actually love this idea. I don't know why we don't talk about it more, but he basically says, claimed that our identity is partly a reflection. We can gain a lot of self-knowledge by appreciating or recognizing how other people see us and their reactions to us essentially help us figure out what behaviors we like and what the kind of person that we want to be, through them, through their appreciation of us. When you ask people questions like, hey, what song reminds you of me? What was I like as a child?
我给陌生人的印象？”比如，几乎所有这些奇奇怪怪的问题，一开始可能会听起来让人感到尴尬，但随后你会真正感到内心被滋养，因为你知道有一个版本的你是存在的，而且它是稳定的，别人能看到这一点并且深爱着你。这个建议在心理学上起作用是因为
You are accessing what psychologist called reflected appraisals. Information about yourself that is stored outside of yourself, that exists outside of the own internal narrative that you have about you, that is quite honestly biased. Research shows these reflected appraisals, they play a really powerful role in shaping our self-concept. especially during periods of transition or identity uncertainty, like our 20s where we can't really trust ourselves to know ourselves sometimes. The memories that we have with other people are like, again, it's like a vault of stuff that stored outside of us that, it's like a bank vault of things that we can go to and be like, oh, that's who I was.
社会心理学中最古老的观点之一，实际上，这是查尔斯·霍顿·库利的“镜中自我”概念。我其实非常喜欢这个观点。我不知道为什么我们没有更多地讨论它，但他基本上指出，声称我们的身份部分是一种映射。我们可以通过欣赏或认识到其他人如何看待我们来获得大量的自我认知，他们对我们的反应本质上可以帮助我们弄清楚我们喜欢什么行为，以及我们想成为什么样的人，通过他们，通过他们对我们的欣赏。当你问别人诸如“嘿，哪首歌能让你想起我？”“我小时候是什么样的？”之类的问题时，
And thank God I stored that with somebody else who isn't going through this tough time. There's also strong evidence from self-verification theory, which was developed in the 80s, we seek feedback from others to stabilize our sense of identity. So when we do feel unsure, family and friends are often one of the most comforting things in that time because they are able to notice patterns, provide that information back to us, and give us a sense of self-continuity. Again, an idea that's come up time and time throughout this episode, the idea that, you know, there is a beginning and an end to our lives, but also there is a story throughout it all that ties together
你正在接触心理学家所说的“反射性评价”。关于你自己的信息，它储存在你自身的外部，存在于你对自己所拥有的、说实话带有偏见的内部叙事之外。研究表明，这些反射性评价在塑造我们的自我概念方面发挥着非常强大的作用，尤其是在转型期或身份不确定的时期，比如我们的二十多岁，有时我们真的无法相信自己能真正了解自己。我们与其他人共同拥有的记忆就像是，再次说明，它就像一个储存在我们外部的宝库，它就像一个银行金库，我们可以去那里并说：“哦，原来那就是我。”
and makes sense and has us as a main character. So finally, my last actionable insight for this episode, I want you to take all of this and I want you to write out a person I want to be letter. So I did this the other day because I was feeling, as you can probably tell, slightly on moored and I was in a hotel room and I was feeling very inspired by the new year as we are and I just sat down and I just wrote five large themes for the person I most wanted to be not for the next year just for my life like five large paragraphs on like if my character and my best self was siphoned down into five things what would they be and why Why is that who I want to be? And I obviously used I statements. Like, I think one of them was,
谢天谢地，我把那段记忆存放在了别人那里，而那个人并没有经历这段艰难时期。自我验证理论也有强有力的证据，该理论发展于80年代，我们从他人那里寻求反馈来稳定我们的身份感。所以当我们确实感到不确定时，家人和朋友往往是这段时间最令人慰藉的力量之一，因为他们能够注意到模式，将这些信息反馈给我们，并赋予我们一种自我延续感。再次说明，这个观点在这集节目中多次出现，即我们的生活有开始也有结束，但在这一切当中还有一个贯穿始终的故事，它将一切联系在一起，
a couple of them were, I'm someone who really takes care of myself. That is somebody that I want to be. That is my ideal person I want to be self. I am someone who others find kind and welcoming. That is a huge part of my values and the person I want to be. I am someone who is surrounded by friends. And I wrote out, you know, there was a couple more, but I wrote out what that looks at, what that looks like, what that would look like in practice on a day-to-day basis in my life. So much of what we focused on in this episode is kind of like reclaiming the personality of the past, but finding yourself again rediscovering your personality also means thinking about your future ideal self. There is this idea in personality, psychology, and in some therapy self-help circles that
使其合情合理，并让我们成为主角。所以最后，关于本集我的最后一个可执行的见解，我希望你吸收所有这些，并写下一封“我想成为的人”的信。前几天我写了这封信，因为正如你可能看出的那样，我当时感觉有点迷茫，我正待在一个酒店房间里，我被新年深深地启发了，正如我们现在这样，我坐下来，为我最想成为的那种人写下了五个宏大的主题，不是为接下来的一年，而是为我的一生，比如写了五大段落，如果将我的个性和最好的自我提炼成五件事，它们会是什么，以及为什么这就是我想成为的人？我显然使用了第一人称陈述。比如，我想其中一个主题是，
if you don't have a representation of how you most want to be, you are not going to end up. there accidentally. The best possible self, the person you most want to be, who you see in the future has to be something, somebody that you can articulate, you can feel, you can see, you can understand, you can detail in order to therefore claim. You know, there is this amazing TED talk very aptly titled, Your Real versus Ideal Self that I think you should listen to if you've resonated with this episode that essentially discusses how this kind of exercise, this who do I want to be exercise, helps you bridge the gap between, you know, who you were in the past and a vision that you most certainly have about your future self that you just, you need to bring to the surface in order to
其中有几个是，我是一个非常照顾自己的人。那是我想要成为的人。那是我理想中“我想成为的人”的自我。我是一个被别人认为善良且受欢迎的人。这是我价值观和我想成为的人的巨大组成部分。我是一个被朋友环绕的人。我写下了，你知道的，还有几个，但我写下了这在现实中是什么样子的，在我的日常生活中实际表现会是怎样的。我们在这一集里关注的很大一部分内容就像是找回过去的个性，但重新找到自己、重新发现你的个性也意味着思考你未来理想中的自我。在人格心理学和一些治疗自助圈子里有这样一个观点，即
become, you know, each one of you has 15 minutes to tonight to try this or 15 minutes tomorrow to do it. And if you're really feeling detached, listen, at most it can't hurt. You can do this in 15 minutes. It's going to make you feel better. Personally, it's so motivating as well. You will feel a wave of energy and you will feel like yourself again. What a little cliche. What a little nice way to wrap up the episode. So as we finish up here, it's just a quick summary of what we talked about today. If you're feeling unlike yourself, if you're feeling stuck, lost, your personality is something that you have control over. It is something that you can reclaim and change. The best ways to go about this are to, number one, revisit your childhood
如果你没有关于你最想成为什么样的人的愿景，你就不会偶然地最终成为那样的人。最好可能的自我，你最想成为的人，你在未来看到的样子，必须是你能够阐明、能够感受到、能够看到、能够理解、能够详细描述的东西、某个人，以便因此去实现它。你知道，有一个非常棒的TED演讲，非常贴切地题为《你的真实自我与理想自我》，如果你对这集节目有共鸣，我认为你应该听听看，它本质上讨论了这种练习，即“我想成为谁”的练习，如何帮助你缩小差距，介于你在过去的那个你和你对未来自己的坚定愿景之间，你只需要将这个愿景带到表面，以便
memories and hobbies, fulfill your soul needs, pursue novel environments, set unproductive goals, start journaling, junk journaling in particular, ask the people, people who know you best, what makes you the best, and write the person I want to be letter. I hope these tips have helped you. Seriously, if you have made it this far, can I just say you are not alone in this? Every day you probably pass multiple people on the street, feeling something very similar right now. Most of them will never do anything about it. So the fact that you are listening and that you don't want to exist on autopilot is just marvelous and incredible and shows that you have everything that you need to rediscover or just discover for the
成为那样的人。你知道，你们每个人今晚都有15分钟的时间来尝试这个，或者明天有15分钟的时间来做这件事。如果你真的觉得与自我脱节了，听着，最坏的情况它也不会伤害你。你可以在15分钟内完成这个。这会让你感觉更好。就个人而言，这也极具激励作用。你会感到一股能量涌上心头，你会觉得自己又找回了自我。多么老套的小建议。多么完美又美好的方式来为这集节目收尾。所以在我们快要结束的时候，简单总结一下我们今天讨论的内容。如果你觉得自己不在状态，如果你感到卡住、迷失，你的个性是你能够掌控的东西。它是你可以找回和改变的东西。最好的方法是，第一，重温你的童年
first time who you are. You know, we all go through times like this. And I think it says a lot about your intrinsic character that you want to change and that you've been able to recognize the state that you're in. So congratulations for making it this far. And if you have made it this far, my request for you is to leave a series of emojis down below if you're listening on Spotify that best encompass your personality as you know it. Whatever emojis come to mind, attract you, feel like a representation of you, drop them down below. Consider it a bonus self-evaluation exercise and thank you for listening all the way through as you have done. Make sure you are following along wherever you are listening, following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. We also have a
回忆和爱好，满足你的心灵需求，追求新颖的环境，设定非生产性的目标，开始写日记，尤其是垃圾手帐，向最了解你的人询问是什么让你成为了最好的自己，以及写下“我想成为的人”的信。我希望这些建议对你有所帮助。说真的，如果你听到了这里，我能说的是，在这条路上你并不孤单。每天你可能都会在街上擦肩而过许多人，他们现在内心也有着非常相似的感受。他们中的大多数人永远不会采取任何行动。所以，你正在收听并且不希望人生处于自动驾驶状态这一事实，简直是奇妙而不可思议的，这表明你拥有重新发现或者第一次发现
substack if you prefer reading or want to revisit this episode. using our transcripts. You can join us over there. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app,
真正的自己所需的一切。你知道，我们都会经历这样的时期。我认为这很能说明你内在的品格，你想改变，而且你能够认出自己目前的精神状态。所以祝贺你坚持听到了这里。如果你已经听到了这里，我对你的请求是，如果你在Spotify上收听，请在下方留下最能概括你所了解的你的人格的一系列表情符号。无论什么表情符号浮现在你的脑海中、吸引你、让你觉得能代表你，把它们留在下方。把这当作一项额外的自我评估练习，感谢你一路听到最后。确保在你收听的任何地方关注我们，在Instagram上关注我们：@That Psychology Podcast。如果你更喜欢阅读或想重温本集节目，我们也有
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
Substack。你可以通过我们的文字记录加入我们。但直到下次，保重，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样去做，在iHeart Radio应用程序上收听《Learn the Hard Way》，
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me.
Apple Podcasts，或您获取播客的任何地方。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健身以及在这个奇异的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。就在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，搜索T-W-O-%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过，她们便决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他绝不能就这样逃脱。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
他一定会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。就在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。在播客节目《Look Back at it》中。从1979年开始，那对我和说是一个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、喜剧同仁和最喜欢的作家一起。马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。那是个疯狂的年份。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。